vom luftalarm den es schon wieder
gegeben hat lassen sie sich nicht
abhalten wer jung ist in odessa der geht
heute zum konzert lokaler bands unten im
keller läuft der soundcheck von alien
kol
[Musik]
sie spielen eine mischung aus punkrock
alternate heavy metal und erzählen uns
zum namen der band haben sie die
umstände inspiriert wir haben gedacht
pandemie krieg was filter ein angriff
von aliens außerirdischen deshalb haben
wir uns allen call genannt
sie leben in einer zeit in der sie von
sieges von durchhalteparolen umgeben
sind und das heißt frontstadt und auch
die vier von alien call haben freunde
und freundinnen die im krieg kämpfen
oder geflüchtet sind und die auch im
proberaum irgendwie mit dabei sind
wir machen wieder musik weil das der
einzige trost während des horrors des
krieges es hilft uns abzulenken
das was jetzt passiert es traurig und
schmerzhaft für uns alle
im richtigen leben den sie noch zur uni
machen marketing auf social media aber
sie wissen auch dass der krieg ihre
generation prägen wird
unsere aufgabe ist es zu überleben
gesund zu bleiben auch psychisch ich
hoffe dieser krieg endet so schnell wie
möglich damit wir realisieren können was
überhaupt passiert ist um zu verstehen
was für eine generation wir sind
es ist schwer das zu realisieren wir
gewöhnen uns oft dran wenn es vor zwei
monaten noch angst einflößend war ist es
jetzt am schlimmsten dass wir anfangen
den zustand zu akzeptieren
und dass das jetzt das echte leben ist
das ist nicht okay wir sollten uns daran
nicht gewöhnen
wir haben einen nachbarn die russische
föderation die uns an teil unserer
zukunft genommen hat
und was noch schlimmer ist das hat viele
leben von ukraine an gekostet die wir
nicht zurückbekommen werden muss wir
sind am leben und können weiter leben
leben zwischen trauer und der hoffnung
dass es irgendwann besser wird das
gefühl dass der krieg ihrer generation
gerade vieles nimmt kennen auch die
konzertbesucher
ja viele leute fühlen das verpasste
möglichkeiten sie können das land nicht
verlassen oder sich persönlich
weiterentwickeln
wer nicht alles funktioniert
die schlechten nachrichten sind überall
wenn ich hierher komme dann kann ich
einfach mal mit man freunden
zusammensitzen musikhören chillen
in jedem fall meine jugend mein leben
geht weiter ich muss irgendwas machen
das konzert von alien call läuft gut an
diesem abend die vier sind ganz
optimistisch irgendwann spielen wir die
stadien
bis dahin machen sie weiter irgendwie
die ukraine zu verlassen kann sich
keiner von ihnen vorstellen
[Musik]